طالبان تحرق يوما بعد يوم وبيدها لا بيد
غيرها كرتنتلو الاخر لانهاء عزلتها
الدوليه
فالحركه التي ظهرت والى التسعيليات من
القرن الماضي الى ان برز نجمها في
افغانستان خليفه عام
1994 الى الان تعيد دوران عقارب الساعه
عكس اتجاهها
حكم الطالبان افغانستان للمره الاولى في
الفتره من
1996 وحتى العام 2001 ووعدت حينها باحلال
السلام والامن والاحترام حقوق الانسان
بمجرد وصولها للسلطه ذلك ما لم يتحقق حضره
الطالبان مشاهده التلفزيون والاستماع الى
الموسيقى وارتياد الدور السينما ورفضت
الذهاب الفتيات من سن العاشره الى المدارس
ودخلت لحركه في عزله دوليه كبيره
تمت الاطاحه حينها بطالبان ولاحقتها تهم
ارتكاب انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان
ودخلت في حرب الواسعه النطاق ثم لا حسوا
الحركه مجددا خلال سنوات القليله الماضيه
في افغانستان حيث توفرت فرصه اخرى في ظل
محاوله الغرب دعمها وخلق مساحه للمفاوضات
عادت الحركه الجديده عقبا سحاب القوات
الامريكيه من البلاد العام الماضي
وبسطت سيطرتها بالكامل وفي خضم اعاده دم
الحركه كان الحديث في ذلك الوقت المطالبه
بتقديم المساعده من المجتمع الدولي وفق
تعهدات للمجتمع الافغاني والعالمي وهي
تعهدات لم تحقق منها الحركه شيئا ومنها ما
تم مؤخرا من حظر الدراسه الجامعيه على
الفتيات
هو كان التاريخ يعيد نفسه من جديد اضاع
الطالبان فرصه من يدها وقطعت شوط اخر
للوراء عصام عبد السلام العربيه